[Music]
we got to take our minds off some of the
stuff that's worrying us these days
north korea you little worried about
north korea or not
[Music]
what was that
they're either very worried or they've
been drinking a lot
you know the more they talk about north
korea more weird facts come out little
weird fun facts about kim jong-un did
you know this this came out today when
kim jong-un was young he apparently
wanted to become an actor
that's true yeah but of course it's hard
to do dinner theater in a country that
doesn't have theater or dinner
slight problem
cause yeah
that'd be a problem
this was a big story true it's been
reported that in high school north
korean leader kim jong-un starred in a
production of the musical greece
yeah the show would end each night with
sandy singing to kim you're the one that
i want
right
[Music]
are you the unit i want
that was great thank you all right
that's really it's really my one talent
that's all right
at least we found it uh jake
jay-z
jay-z and beyonce have created a
controversy by traveling to cuba and the
treasury department is now saying that
when they okayed the request they didn't
know it was them
yeah
yeah the department said we thought it
was a different jay-z and beyonce
[Applause]
there's a lot of them running around
uh i don't know who here has a chrysler
anybody have a chrysler
wow okay
are they sponsors jeff on the show oh
they are
we're going to take that applause there
and in editing added over to how many
people have a chrysler
we don't have the money to do that uh
over a quarter of a million chrysler
vehicles are being recalled for problems
with fuel tanks brakes engines airbags
and electrical wiring
on the plus side chrysler insists our
cup holders have never been safer
fantastic yeah your drink is safe you
want
yeah
i love chrysler too all right
ding hey uh former representative
anthony weiner remember him he famously
tweeted lewd photos of himself now says
he wants people to give him a second
chance
yeah not in politics but on instagram
well his penis looks so much better with
a golden globe yeah
[Music]
sort of a haze yeah
i think that's getting a delayed people
were thinking about it
like yeah like an old-timey piece
lot of guys here are like yeah it's
gonna look good
click uh
the latest internet photo trend have you
heard of it it involves harry potter
fans sitting on a broomstick in
different locales and it's called
pottering
yeah
it's very simple all you need is a broom
a camera and zero friends to talk you
out of it
[Music]
there was a harry potter section over
here
yay we love watering
and then i make fun of it and they get
real sad
their wands go
today flavorflave is going to court on a
possible felony charge
the judge has set flavor flav's bail at
one hundred thousand dollars or three of
his teeth
thank you
a new report just came out claims that
almost half of justin bieber's 37
million twitter followers are fake
even more disturbing the other half are
real
[Applause]
[Music]
a story out of japan japanese engineers
this is true have created what they call
a girlfriend jacket
that replicates the sensation of being
hugged by a woman from behind
that's a true story
once again japanese engineers remain on
the cutting edge of creepy loneliness
can you imagine
who wants to be high from behind
yeah
oh it's the code i remember now